you know why it's upsetting I was
thinking about you cuz you just had two
how old is the baby now he's gonna be a
year on May 5th like this is when you
would be taking them for a stroll with
the stroller now it's like you live in a
world where you have to be terrified of
other people and bringing the baby
around other people we like fled New
York a couple weeks ago but while we
were in New York it was really awful you
know we were taking him outside less and
less and then all of a sudden paparazzi
were showing up because I think everyone
else left New York and I'm a celebrity
left yeah really I felt bad for them and
I was like guys like I'm leaving town
they were like oh you can't leave yeah
like well where are you going like well
here I'll be at this address um oh wait
you want to see the baby oh yeah that
maybe had you produced let's see what I
want yeah oh my goodness he's so cute he
is cute Robbie
by the way I love this story that you
gave Jeanne a middle name oh yeah -
David tell the great comedian you're not
gonna tell on this this is so great Amy
and her husband they like the comedian
Dave Attell they have a real apparently
they love Dave Attell right and so Amy
gave jean baby jean the name jean Attell
and you know for a middle name and then
when did you realize that that really
sounded like Janet L genital like a
month in I mean you know you're like the
new parents like just kind of tired and
an ecstasy and then I don't know it's
like some troll on the internet or
somebody and I read it and I was like oh
my god because you know you're wearing a
jean a towel like it just me who's like
a filthy person like it never Donna me
and I was all the blood rushed to my
head and I was like Chris and and
everyone's like saying and I think it's
a big deal I don't think it's a big deal
I'm like what are you Thai boy named Sue
sued my son maybe i right out the gate
name and Chris's Leslie was Fisher so
it's genital Fisher Oh Fisher the first
of many
failure like he's starting out as a new
mom and you already [ __ ] up you know
who the real sad part of that story is
poor Dave Attell I me Haven pal you know
cuz he's like my really good friend for
and I've known him my whole life
actually and and he's really humble you
know he's just like oh I don't know I
don't know and then but he's really
moved by it you could see and then we
had to just quote and his name right at
him but we did use it to David so it's
his first name at first I thought well
maybe Amy's going for the laugh with the
kid you know [ __ ] it and go you know
like maybe go all in the next Kittel be
curly pubes or something you know I know
everybody gave me credit and I was just
like no that is just a huge [ __ ]
you